hey everyone I'm Abby from Abby's
kitchen welcome back to our series
enlightened by intuitive eating so in
our last video we were discussing
principle number five of intuitive
eating feel your fullness so if you have
not yet watched that video I recommend
going back to check it out here and then
of course coming back to watch this one
also I want to give a big big big thank
you to Alyssa Rumsey intuitive eating
dietitian for consulting on this video
I'm you believe all her contact
information in the description below in
case you're interested on doing any
one-on-one consulting now before we get
started I want to flag that this content
may not be suitable for all of my
viewers so feel free to take and leave
what you find valuable and of course
don't forget to follow the intuitive
eating journey along with me through
evelyn tripoli and elise russia's book
intuitive eating which i have linked
below as well now let's first get into a
reader question dear abby
i'm on a medication that causes me to
feel really hungry all the time how is
it that I can practice intuitive eating
if my medication gets in the way of my
natural hunger cues now this is such a
great question and one that I often get
so certain medications can make a person
ravenously hungry or they can suppress
hunger either way
balance and eating with these
conflicting messages can feel like a
real struggle some kind medications that
people report an increase in hunger
include domperidone which is an
off-label drug for breast milk
production antidepressants like SSRIs
like Prozac and lexapro mood stabilizers
like clozaril
diabetes medication like insulin and
Victoza corticosteroids like prednisone
and prednisolone and oral contraceptives
on the flip side some common medications
that may decrease hunger signals include
things like diabetes medication like
metformin or januvia certain cancer
medications that result in nausea and
vomiting like chemotherapy or radiation
and certain antibiotics so the key with
intuitive eating is of course to focus
on your body's hunger cues and this can
be really hard when the medication not
your physical needs is dictating these
cues in the case of those who feel
ravenously hungry it's important to
still listen to your hunger sing
and eat when you feel hungry while
focusing on adding in filling foods that
will satisfy that hunger so for example
things like fiber rich carbs plus some
protein and fat in those who have their
appetite suppressed and get full quickly
and maybe more helpful to focus on
smaller more frequent meals and snacks
so that way you can still get enough
nutrients throughout the day without
feeling overly full so in some cases you
could ask your doctor for an alternative
medication that doesn't have some of
these side effects however if that's not
possible
it may be a bit of trial and error to
find foods that satisfy you while still
meeting your nutrient needs at the end
of the day an appetite increase or some
weight gain may be a side effect but if
the medication is helping your physical
or mental health then the trade-off may
absolutely be worth it when in doubt of
course it's always best to speak to your
doctor and a registered dietician who
can give you the best advice on how to
deal with the side effects of your
unique medication okay so on that note
let's move on to the video so in today's
video we're gonna be discussing
principle number six discover the
satisfaction factor now the pressure to
be thin is more alive than ever
whether you're scrolling through your
social media grabbing a magazine while
in line of the grocery store or watching
a commercial on TV you are constantly
constantly bombarded with messages to
lose weight become thin and diet diet
diet but our thin obsessed society has
forgotten about some of our main
psychological drives those being
pleasure and satisfaction in eating now
a lot of attention is paid to paying
attention to how full you feel and how
to stop eating when you feel that
fullness but by focusing only on
fullness we miss out on a really
important part of intuitive eating and
that is satisfaction satisfaction
differs significantly from fullness I
like to think of fullness as the
physical feeling of being full while
satisfaction is like the mental feeling
of being full you could be physically
full but not mentally satisfied with
or the opposite could happen you could
feel satisfied mentally with the taste
and when you ate but not necessarily
physically full according to Maslow's
hierarchy of needs which I talked about
back in principle number to honor your
hunger humans are driven by our unmet
needs we always want what we can't have
and we will go out of our way to attain
it or will drive ourselves crazy at
least just trying to when it comes to
eating satisfaction is actually one of
the main drivers that will turn on or
off our drive to eat sure we eat for
nourishment and to manage our hunger and
we can stop eating when we feel full but
we choose specific foods based on what
we ultimately like and feeling satisfied
after a meal is really what makes us
stop when we're done so a foods taste
texture and smell all play a huge role
in our food decisions humans are
generally able to differentiate between
the five tastes so that is sweet salty
bitter sour edamame and this helps us
determine if a food is safe enjoyable
and if it will meet our physiological
needs so for example our biological need
for energy through carbohydrates like
sugar also yes I am aware that there is
a debate over fats being the sixth taste
but that's gonna have to be a whole
other video if you're interested now
when selecting foods we really want them
to hit the spot so to speak so if you're
in the mood for pasta but instead you
choose a salad it's not going to be very
satisfying or for example let's say
you're not even that hungry and you surf
a huge platter of food even though the
food may be normally really satisfying
it won't be if you're already really
full from a previous meal you ate
satisfaction really changes based on our
current situation so if your ravenously
hungry and you end up eating very
quickly you may not experience as much
satisfaction compared to a meal where
maybe you had less urgency to eat and
are able to really savor the flavors in
the food that you're eating same thing
applies if you're distracted and eating
you're likely paying attention to the
task at hand whatever that might be
and you're not paying attention to the
experience of eating so as a result you
make it to the end of a meal and not
even really remember eating at all which
of course means you're less likely to
feel satisfied when we go against our
drive for satisfaction this can really
backfire for example let's say you're
really craving a bag of chips you think
about it and you think about it and then
you think oh that's not a good option so
you avoid eating them and instead you
eat a few rice cakes a few hours goes by
and you're still thinking about those
chips so you eat some more rice cakes
and then maybe you eat some fruit and
then maybe you eat a piece of toast and
then maybe meet a bowl of cereal and
you're still thinking about those chips
and then you think oh my gosh I'm just
gonna have one chip and then you can't
help yourself
but eat the entire bag of chips now
although a lot of these alternatives may
be healthier choices a lot of the time
you just end up eating more than had you
just had a few potato chips to begin
with so in the chase for healthier foods
you end up trying to fill the void of
satisfaction with other foods and
usually these other foods never give you
that same level of satisfaction rather
if you were just to actually eat some of
the chips the first time around and sit
and enjoy the flavor that you are truly
craving you'll probably just eat them
and move on with your day instead of
spending the entire day trying to run
from it and pacifying that need with all
of these other foods interestingly our
society demonizes the enjoyment of food
so any food that tastes remotely good is
now labeled as being bad we're tempting
or sinful I mean you see this all over
the media where people tout their
success by developing strong willpower
and being able to resist really tasty
food but here's the thing the more you
focus on resisting food the more likely
you are to binge in the future on it
this willpower that people have tends to
be only highlighted from one side and
very rarely do you see the other dark
side of dieting which usually
encompasses binging tremendous feelings
of guilt and a terrible relationship
with one's body and
the key here is to enjoy all food with
no judgment when we take the power away
from food it no longer holds power over
us we eventually learn to appreciate the
satisfying flavors and textures of all
foods and stop feeling the need to
overdo it since it's always available so
I'm sure you're all wondering how do I
rebuild my relationship with food and
learn to enjoy eating again well there
are five main steps that can help you
step one
ask yourself what do I really want to
eat being satisfied with food involves
taking some time out to determine what
it is that you really want to eat and
what sounds really good in that moment
so of course consider the taste but also
think about things like texture
temperature smell I mean are you in the
mood for something sweet salty so in
crunchy warm etc so take time to
consider what you truly want and it may
be really tough to do especially if
you're used to only making decisions on
what to eat based on what you think you
should have so obviously this is going
to take a lot of practice and
experimentation but once you've figured
out what sounds good to you give
yourself unconditional permission to eat
that food and allow yourself to eat it
in a calm relaxing environment I know a
lot of people feel really anxious about
the phrase unconditional permission to
eat and I understand why I mean like
there is no condition or situation where
you would say no to a cupcake but if you
find that you're binging on certain
foods and have a hard time stopping this
may be a sign that you have been
restricting and it's really not working
out for you now I want you to take a
second to think for a moment about the
foods that you truly truly enjoy not the
foods that society has told you that you
should enjoy but the foods that bring a
smile to your face and just like make
you feel really good after eating them
in a lot of cases people really struggle
to answer this question I mean for so
long we're told that we should eat this
we shouldn't eat that and that our food
choices are made
based on the suggestions or pressures of
others so if you're having a really hard
time deciding what foods you genuinely
like I suggest you take a week or so to
test out different foods and flavors
find out what tastes you really like and
what tastes maybe you don't like foods
that make you feel good and those that
make you feel kind of crappy now once
you find out what foods you actually
really like and allow yourself to eat
these foods you'll likely eventually
find yourself eating an amount that
you're actually hungry for because after
that it's not enjoyable and it doesn't
feel or even taste that good when we eat
the foods that we enjoy we don't spend
time eating foods just trying to fill a
void and ultimately we're able to find
satisfaction with the right amount of
food for us in that moment now step 2 is
discover the pleasure of food so if
you're really struggling with finding
what foods you enjoy this step is super
important as you experiment with
different kinds of foods consider the
sensual qualities of food so taste is
the food sweet salty bitter sour do you
enjoy it when do you enjoy it at
breakfast lunch dinner do these things
change throughout the day figuring out
what flavors you enjoy and when you
enjoy them can really help you discover
if a food will satisfy you then there's
texture do you like crunchy foods soft
foods creamy foods does this change
depending on the time of day or the food
can certain textures be more or less
appealing at different times so for
example the idea of eating a crunchy
cabbage salad at 7:00 a.m.
may not be so appetizing but a bowl of
creamy soft oatmeal might be then
there's aroma so many people do not know
this but digestion actually starts
before food even hits our tongue the
smell of food can stimulate the release
of different enzymes that get our mouths
to salivate so for example the smell of
roasted coffee beans in the morning may
rev up your appetite but the smell of
roast beef might not if the smell of the
food is enjoyable for you in the moment
it's likely going to lead to
satisfaction when you eat it
next is appearance I mean this one is he
for people we like food that looks
appetizing
in fact dishes that have more colors
going on tend to be viewed as more
appealing than plates that have very
bland or subdued colors so if you have a
salad with some green lettuce green
peppers and green broccoli it's probably
not gonna look that good but if you had
a salad with some green lettuce red
peppers purple onions and orange carrots
that will probably be way more
interesting and appealing the more
exciting a meal looks ultimately the
more enjoyment we're going to get out of
it this was really one of my main goals
with my book the mindful Glo cookbook
and if you look at the images you'll see
that I am obsessed with color I believe
that if it looks good it's more likely
to be exciting and you're more able to
derive a greater amount of pleasure from
eating it also think about temperature
so time of day mood the weather outside
and other factors can really change how
appealing a certain food temperature is
if it's freezing outside you're probably
going to want something warm and cozy
that's gonna be a little bit more
enjoyable if it's the middle of summer
you'll probably find a hot chocolate not
as appetizing so finding what
temperature of food you enjoy can help
you experience eating even better so do
you like your dinner piping hot or do
you like to give it a few minutes to
cool it down do you like your drinks
with lots of ice or to prefer it closer
to room temperature find what works for
you to make your meals more satisfying
and enjoyable and let's talk about
volume for a second
so some foods are categorized as being
heavy and filling while others are
thought to be more light and airy some
days you may just want foods that are
more filling like a big pasta dinner
while other days you might want a
lighter meal like a salad or soup in
either case it's really about listening
to what your body truly wants even if
these foods are normally tasty to you
you may not find them very appealing if
your stomach is upset or you're already
full so truly every day every meal can
look different I want you to keep in
mind that what one person finds
appetizing
not the appetizing for you or vice-versa
this is totally normal and okay we don't
want to necessarily be yakking somebody
else's young but the amazing thing about
humans is that we're all so different so
find what makes you happy and satisfied
and go with that now when you're
thinking about what you want to eat take
these sensory properties of food into
consideration so think to yourself what
do I want to eat what smells good right
now
what looks really good right now how
would XY and Z food taste at this very
moment and do I want something sweet or
salty or sour what kind of texture of
food do I want am I in the mood for
something hot cold or maybe something in
between more room temperature also how's
my stomach volume right now what a heavy
or light meal feel better
asking these questions can really help
you get to the bottom of what you're
truly wanting rather than just eating
food arbitrarily in hopes that you
figure it out step 3 make eating a more
enjoyable experience if you've ever
visited certain countries in Europe
you'll notice that mealtime is so much
more value to compare to meals here in
North America in some cases businesses
totally just closed down at lunch time
people meet up with friends and family
and most take a lot longer than 20
minutes to eat their lunch in comparison
North Americans tend to eat their lunch
at their desk in front of a TV or their
computer or in their car while driving
if lucky you may have five minutes of
peace to eat your lunch
uninterrupted whatever it is this is
really a very enjoyable experience when
we rush to eat our meals we don't give
ourselves an opportunity to stop and
actually enjoy the experience of eating
think back to a time that you had a nice
family dinner that lasted upwards of an
hour or two you sat down you ate your
food slowly you enjoyed your
conversation sipped your wine and really
experienced eating as it was meant to be
I don't know about you but I rarely get
to experience food like this anymore our
lives are so fast-paced
that we really have lost the sanctity of
eating and enjoying food in exchange for
efficiency and productivity so to work
on intuitive eating I want you to take
time to savor your food and the
experience of eating this doesn't have
to happen at every meal but try to use
some of these tips at one meal at least
every single day so these tips are
dedicate time to eating and eating only
so give yourself a time allowance to
focus only on the active eating even if
it's only 10 or 15 minutes this is way
better than what we normally allow
ourselves to sit down at the table so
eating in front of the television in
your car or even in the kitchen counter
does not set you up for a
distraction-free meal by sitting down at
the table this is really a visual and
physical cue that you're about to eat
and that can increase attention and
overall satisfaction 3 practice deep
breathing so meditation and breathing
focus practices can help calm yourself
down before a meal this increases your
focus on food and away from distractions
which can help you eat slower and more
intuitively that brings me to tip 4 slow
down now remember that the slower you
eat the more flavors and textures you'll
notice this act can really help you get
in tune with the pleasurable aspects of
food and helps you notice as your hunger
levels to gradually decrease one little
tip is to put down your fork and knife
periodically and that can kind of signal
to you to maybe check in with your
hunger and how pleasurable the eating
experience is next don't wait until your
ravenous to eat if you wait until you're
starving to start a meal you're less
likely to enjoy the foods in front of
you because you're so focused on
satisfying your intense hunger in that
moment most people find the most
pleasure in food when they're moderately
hungry so refer back to the hunger scale
that we talked about last week and try
not to let yourself get down to a one or
two too often next avoid tension at
meals I know this is easier said than
done but your eating experience will
definitely suffer if you're focused on
an argument with your friend partner or
family member
let's keep mealtime a sacred fight free
also provide variety lack of food
choices creates a sense of deprivation
and in turn you may end up dedicating a
lot of time to searching for something
to eat try to allow all types of food in
your fridge and cupboards because that
will help you find what you're looking
for when that craving hits and again
over time you'll notice that you won't
always be hunting for cookies or chips
that that doesn't necessarily mean
that's what you're craving but rather
what your body truly wants in that
moment now if you're having a hard time
remembering all this level and trebly
analyse rush give a great and easy way
to remember it they call it the 3 s's
eat slowly eat sensually and savor every
bite another thing to keep in mind is
the environment that you're in is your
kitchen or dining room really messy is
it dark and unwelcoming are you eating
in your car on the go at your work desk
etc ideally you want to eat a room that
feels welcoming with limited
distractions so a good tip is to make
your dining table only for dining
rather than table for multiple tasks
this will limit the amount of chaos you
associate with this environment and
really allows you to focus down on
eating now let's get to step 4 do not
settle now when it comes to a treat of
eating you are in charge if you do enjoy
the food that you're eating you're more
than welcome to keep eating it to your
liking and you also don't have to finish
eating an entire plate of food if you
don't want to you can enjoy food in the
moment and then lose interest as you
take a few more bites
that's the great thing about intuitive
eating there's really no concrete rules
with how much or her little food you
need to eat it's really all up to your
hunger and your preferences so for
example if you're having dinner and you
find that the potatoes are undercooked
then you don't need to feel pressured to
eat all of them just because they're on
your plate instead focus on enjoying the
other foods at the table maybe the
cooked vegetables or the rice or the
chicken or whatever it is that's been
served also it's okay to enjoy the real
deal for example let's say you really
really really loved a particular brand
of chocolate chip cookies but
in an effort to be healthier you try to
make low sugar chocolate chip cookies at
home in a lot of cases the cookie just
is not going to taste the same and let's
be real and never well you don't have to
settle for the healthier cookie just
because you feel like you should enjoy
the product that you truly like I mean
tell yourself I'm only going to eat that
if I'm really going to enjoy it
which can really help prevent overeating
through the trial and error of finding
something like it step 5 check in with
yourself now while you're eating take a
few seconds to really just like reflect
and check in with yourself is eating
this still enjoyable
am I still finding this really tasty in
a lot of cases the first few bites of
any meal are really the best and and it
does start to dwindle after the tenth or
in some cases the 20th bite now in
principle three I talked about a
phenomenon known as habituation which is
the more a person is exposed to a food
the less appealing that food becomes
that is totally normal
now a good way to check in with yourself
is to really rate your taste pleasure at
the beginning of eating a specific food
and then again after a few bites and
then finally when you're done so one
would be the least pleasurable ten would
be the most pleasurable in most cases
you're gonna notice that your taste
rating goes down the more exposure that
you have to that food if you notice that
you're not enjoying the food anymore
then this might be a really good time to
stop and wait until you're hungry again
for more of that food remember that the
food is always available so why waste
your time eating it when you don't
necessarily find it pleasurable anymore
save it for when it does taste great
leftovers can be a beautiful thing now
there may be situations when you can't
do all of these steps of course and that
is totally okay there are going to be
days and you're busy that you have to
eat in the car and there are going to be
days when there are only certain foods
available and maybe you have to eat them
to satisfy your hunger there are going
to be days when you're having a super
busy day so that you know you need to
eat a little bit more
then you're hungry for because you won't
get another chance for six hours
intuitive eating is not a perfect
process but rather it's a guidance to a
healthier relationship with food and
eating finally I get a lot of comments
from some of you that are watching that
say that their family or friends comment
on their food choices I'm here to give
you 100% permission to reclaim your
right to enjoy eating the foods that you
love you do not need to defend your
eating choices to anyone but if you want
to respond you can kindly remind them
that you welcome any foods that bring
you joy into your life and you really
try to encourage them to do the same I
also have a whole video on food and body
shaming with lots of really fun
responses to a lot of these kinds of
family comments so you can check that
out right here now for your homework
this week I want you to focus on
practicing steps 1 through 5 and take
time to figure out the foods that really
bring you joy and pleasure and try to
dedicate the time to eat your meal
slowly again again not every day will be
perfect but the more you focus on
enjoying your meals the more food will
become a friend rather than an enemy
continue to work on these steps
throughout your intuitive eating journey
and stay tuned for our next video on
principle number 7 cope with your
emotions without using food on that note
I hope you all enjoyed this video if you
did be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below if you have any
questions related to intuitive eating
and I may answer them in an upcoming
video don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and I will see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]